hey 42 here pitches are one of the most
incredible inventions snapshots in time
of people places and events frozen
forever along with all those special
memories and feelings attached they can
convey emotion illustrate ideas and even
inspire the human spirit but we mostly
use em to take pictures of our food
let's take a look at some interesting
facts you may not know about one of the
most popular photography and social
networking gaps out there Instagram the
computer code powering the social media
powerhouse known as Instagram was
written over a period of eight weeks by
co-founder Kevin Systrom
though he says that over a year of work
went into the final product he taught
himself the art of computer programming
in the late hours after his day job
developing a few basic ideas that helped
him to hone his programming skills
whilst laying down the groundwork for
the app we know and love the name
Instagram is a mash-up of instant and
telegram it was inspired by the way that
snapshots are taken with the app and
then sent over the wire to others sure
it's not technically accurate but it's a
hell of a lot catchier than is to
teleport your pictures through the air
the popular trend of making nostalgic
post to social media known as throwback
Thursday first began on Instagram so
remember to thank Instagram the next
time your friends showed that old
embarrassing photo of you the app was
initially released on October the 6th
2010 it figuratively exploded overnight
gathering over 1 million registered
users by the end of the year by December
of 2011 Apple named Instagram net up of
the year and the world of hastily posted
meal photography with a filter slapped
on top hasn't been the same since former
wrestler and Hollywood superstar Dwayne
the rock Johnson organized a crowd of
fans at a movie premiere in London in
order to break the world record for most
selfies taken in free minutes as
recognized by the Guinness Book of World
Records in November of 2010 the
Instagram team made the decision to move
into an empty
office in San Francisco's South Park but
it wasn't just any old office it was a
former first office of another social
media powerhouse known as Twitter hot
off their first month of resounding
success the fledgling team was eager to
make a statement to the rest of Silicon
Valley they were ready to join the big
leagues popular musician Ellie Goulding
created an entire music video for her
song anything could happen
using nothing but fun submitted
Instagram photos the video features 1200
photo stitch together with some snazzy
editing for the entire three minutes and
51 seconds on time immortalizing her
lucky fans for as long as YouTube
persists equal parts creepy and cool
Instagram allows you to tag your current
geographical location when you snap a
selfie using their photo map feature you
can see every place you and your friends
have taken pictures for better or worse
just remember not to take your location
when you just called in sick to work but
you're actually undone impromptu camping
trip with your mates in 2012 Facebook
purchased Instagram for an estimated 1
billion u.s. dollars in cold hard cash
and company stocks Instagram Twitter
account has made six thousand four
hundred and ninety seven posts for its
thirty nine point six million followers
it only follows free users in turn
Instagram at music and the two
cofounders of the company however even
with that many followers it lands only
12 on the list of the most followed
Twitter accounts we hand the likes of
Barack Obama YouTube and Twitter itself
one of instagrams early prototypes was
titled bourbon named after one of
co-founders Kevin system's favorite
drinks the most popular filter on
Instagram is actually no filter at all
sometimes a good picture just speaks for
itself
other times you really should address it
up at least a little bit the line
between those two worlds is perilously
thin my friends as of January 2015
Instagram sees traffic from over 300
million monthly active users that's a
whole lot of people chronicling the
minutiae
day of their lives with the humble
photography up according to a study
performed by AT&T a staggering 70
percent of drivers admit to using their
phones whilst driving from that group of
naughty drivers 14 percent admits to
have been using Instagram who knows in
the future public awareness campaigns
might be telling you not to add filters
to selfies and drive the first Instagram
photo was uploaded on July the 16th 2010
whilst the app was still in development
two short years later after the first
test picture was uploaded over 1 billion
users shared photos had joined it in the
cloud the most followed account on
Instagram is unsurprisingly Instagram
itself next in line is the ever-popular
singer and actress Beyonce with almost
40 million followers as of July 2015
following closely behind is the no less
influential but perhaps far more
controversial Kim Kardashian with around
39 million followers in a study which
included many Instagram source photos it
was determined that filtered photographs
are 21 percent more likely to be viewed
and 45 percent more likely to be
commented on by viewers the spike in
engagement was most noteworthy with
filters that boosted the pitchers warmth
exposure and contrast back in 2012 when
Instagram was managed by just 15
employees and still surging with
bewildering popularity certain unsavory
types began to use it as a platform for
sharing x-rated images since then the
development team has worked hard to tone
down the titillating content in favor of
more family-friendly fare but have they
succeeded in January of 2015 an
Instagram user had their account banned
for showing a little too much besides
their bikini to put it bluntly her pubic
hair was on show Instagram reversed
their decision in short order after
reviewing the case and determining that
there is no actual nudity on display but
a staunch debate continues to rage on to
this day between Instagram and the
feminist community over what should be
sensible material thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42